[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur verließ
welt mit diesem video leuten wird die
weihnachts winterzeit dieses jahr ein
ich weiß von 70 auf den ersten blick
aber ich bin gerade nicht zu hause
ich bin gerade in mannheim in unserem
shop kaufen ja schon mal eine rundum
drehung
zumal alle fleißigen helferlein sag mal
hanau und ich würde sagen ich richte
meine zutaten die mädels und jungs
fangen schon mal an zu dekorieren und
dann geht's los jetzt was leckeres haben
wir uns noch mal weihnachten die
nachrichten laden nach mannheim rein
kommt sowas weihnachtlich aussehen die
leute sollen das lachen und sicher
freuen
ich habe eine kutsche besorgt kann sich
dann als weihnachtsmann verkleidet und
seit diesem tag fotos machen also wir
samstags immer war ich habe eine kutsche
und die pin code es mir weihnachten also
mit mir war perfekt als er kaum ablehnen
und wir tun alles was geht
ich hoffe sie schaffen uns integriert ab
[Musik]
also seht schon in monza alle versammelt
an dem sonntag denn unter der woche und
am betrieb können wir das gar nicht
machen fit schön dekoriert die dicken
hammer im prinzip alles schon sortiert
alles was herbst war um sommer war raus
bieten so vielleicht kann der den
weihnachtsmann spielen bleibt heute york
rundschau wir zweimal viel blödsinn
jaja team bleibt sind könnt ihr team
sterne sein weil ihr koalition hänge
kuba bestellt kann stoffteile okay und
ich höre mich ganz kurz um es groß damit
es aufgehen kann und dann helfe ich mit
immer so zwischendurch josef kremer hin
oder com stream ag
[Musik]
also habe ich hier mal die zutaten hier
vorne schon alles wird in einen topf
aber ich werde jetzt zuerst mal das brot
ohne kneten vorbereiten
da gibt es bereits ein rezept auf einem
kanal ich mache jetzt praktisch das
grundrezept ich habe es keinen sattel
sirup dem stattdessen honig habe ich
noch in essig hefe wasser salz
dinkelmehl und dann verfeinern ich das
ganze noch mit pinienkernen röstzwiebeln
und getrockneten tomaten und die
getrockneten tomaten die sind bereits in
so kleine feine streifen geschnitten und
im prinzip heißer das brot ohne kneten
weil man es eben nicht leben muss das
heißt alle zutaten einfach verrühren
ich mache es so ich geh jetzt hier mal
das wasser rein gleich helfen
ich brauche hilfe matamata herrscht in
der mittleren gemacht die hilfe ist auch
ein problem damit sich die hefe kurz
auflösen kann bestand genau lauwarm
damals ein paar zitronig rein 3 erst
mache das schon mal ganz praktisch so
dann erst sich dazu und jetzt kräftig
wenn sich alles verbunden hat gebe ich
noch salz dazu dass ihr mann nicht
direkt zur hilfe sondern eher zum
fertigen teig den hefe und salz
vertragen sich nicht so gut genauso wie
50 weitere ist anstrengend
[Musik]
ich gebe es noch ein bisschen wasser
dazu denn ihr seht schon denken verträgt
ruhig ein bisschen mehr wasser jetzt
aber soll ich einfach so lange rühren
bis sich alles gut verbunden hat das ist
eine große menge mit einem kilometer bei
einer kleineren menge das schlüssel
einfacher das hat sich jetzt super
verbunden und ich nehme jetzt einfach
für die samira weil die gerne ohne alles
hat ein bisschen was heraus
in den restlichen teig geben wir es tun
haben und da können wir einfach
entscheiden was ihr gerne habt
dann wäre das jetzt schon mal fertig den
gebe ich jetzt also entweder deckt den
es ab und lasst den zwei stunden bei
raumtemperatur stehen oder gebt ihnen in
den dampf backofen bei der stufe so
ungefähr 30 bis 34 grad da geht es
nämlich um die hälfte schneller also da
brauche ich wirklich nur eine stunde bis
er sich verdoppelt
das machen wir kurz und dann für
wirklich direkt um den eindruck hatte
ich das große wort zu gut rein
und dann hier auf dampf der stufe ich
mache dann meist auf 34 runter und dann
machen wir das ganze auf eine stunde
hier sind jetzt mal die zutaten die ich
für den eintopf geplant habe denn das
ganze soll es um gewinnt eindruck werden
schön settings wärmend und einfach
lecker ich glaube das wird lag der
eindruck ist es mit fleisch aber wir
können natürlich auch ohne fleisch
zubereiten dann ist es sogar vegan aber
dabei uns dem rat mit ist und für den
murat fleisch alles ist gibt es
natürlich in fleischigen ein text kaum
sage ich fleisch kommt da um die ecke
geschossen
da war karten an der kasse
himmelsstürmer gleichstellung dekorieren
dann mach ich habe jetzt hier 1,7 kilo
rinderschmorbraten 2 zwiebeln nicht mehr
mit sie eine rote oder weiße 2
knoblauchzehen etwa 102 kilo kartoffeln
hier habe ich jeweils 300 gramm
pastinaken und petersilienwurzel 600
gramm karotten knolle gemüsebrühe resch
marin
ich habe ich erbsen aus dem tk dann noch
die gewürze salz pfeffer petersilie 90
paprika lorbeer und ein wirbel wie komme
ich oft petersilie ist es paprika
edelsüß genau und die wichtigste zutat
das olivenöl kommt gleich das packen wir
nämlich gerade noch aus denn das ohnehin
deniz endlich da was jetzt machen werde
ich werde zuerst mal das ganze gemüse
waschen putzen schälen
ja das machen wir jetzt im zeitraffer
denn das dauert ansonsten zu lange
[Musik]
eine einlieferung rainbow ja schön mein
rainbow olivenöl mein gott also dem
brief brauche ich jetzt lese ich weiß
auch was der morath viel unsinn
geschrieben hat auch lecker ich kochte
es erst einmal mit olivenöl aus meiner
flasche specials ups das wurzelgemüse
arbeitsmarkt gewaschen also geschält und
gewaschen
was jetzt hier mache beim lauf das mache
ich immer ganz gern im anschluss da
schalte ich unten die wurzel weg dann
schneide ich da hinten diese dunklen
blättern so das holzige außen und weil
auch gerne auch in der mitte sehr sehr
sandig und mach ich's dann nämlich so
dass ich den in ringe schneiden und dann
warte ich den hier einfach in so einer
salatschleuder war dann bekommt ihr
wirklich komplett allesamt erster raus
[Musik]
als nächstes mache ich jetzt einfach so
ich werde das erst mal das ganze gemüse
schneiden und hier in der schüssel geben
dann ist das schon mal bereich und dann
später noch fleisch fleisch nach dem
schluss beim fenster den schneide ich
jetzt einfach in streifen
und ich habe mir gedacht ja noch zwei
äpfel mit rein die bringen so eine
leichte süße mit rein
ich glaube es passt echt gut
[Musik]
so gehört unser vegan wolken kommt auch
das muss ich so ein teil praktisch ohne
fleisch machen deswegen schneide ich
jetzt auch erstmal das ganze gemüse
damit es nicht ihren kontakten im
fleisch kommt
[Musik]
und alles an gemüse einfach grob würfeln
so wie ihr es gerne haben möchte optisch
stopp gewürfelt ist cool doch
[Musik]
ja ich sag jetzt das was ich immer sage
man hätte ja auch eine größere schüssel
nehmen manchmal auch danke hab mich
schon beobachtet perfekt
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich hier schon mal das
fleisch nehmen wie gesagt ich hab so ein
rinderschmorbraten und das schneide ich
jetzt auch ganz einfach in würfelchen
wie so ein gulasch
[Musik]
was sich zum fleisch noch sagen wir ganz
wichtig ist dass das zimmer warme ist
das heißt wirklich nicht direkt aus dem
kühlschrank holen sondern erst mal auf
rat bekommen lassen wir vorerst anbraten
denn dann wird das fleisch wird wenn es
nämlich ganz kalt ist und dann in die
heiße pfanne kommt dann können durchaus
vorstellen es wie wenn man aus der sauna
kommt und dann in so eiskaltes wasser
springt dann zieht man er so zusammen
und da wird es das fleisch neben
aufsetzt und nämlich auch sehr zäh und
daher wirklich schön auf raumtemperatur
kommen lassen
[Musik]
ich nehme das hier mal ab das könnte ja
schön an eure kette armband hängen was
hört mit meiner stimme los sondern hier
im großen topf am besten nehmen ein
bisschen olivenöl rein schön erwärmen
auf mit hoher hitze
also mein herz gtc bis 9 da hat auch
bewusst aber wenn ich mit gusseisen
arbeit dass er wirklich material was
werbe gut speichert und auch gut wieder
abgibt das heißt dann müsst ihr nicht
auf volle pulle arbeiten sondern
wirklich eher auf mittlerer hitze mittel
hoch ich mache jetzt hier auf 8
ja und dann wird das fleisch
stationspreise portionsweise angebraten
das heißt ich nehme meine kleine portion
bratsche schön scharf an und nehmen sie
damit daraus
[Musik]
zwischenzeit nutzen und die zwiebel und
knoblauch würfeln
[Musik]
ok yoshiko auf stufe 7 ist okay das
mittel hoch jetzt wirklich nur so viel
fleisch da reingeben bis der boden
bedeckte nicht zu viel auf einmal
wenn wir nicht so viel rein geht beim
typ der topf oder die panik kindern
schnell ab und dann sport und reden kann
man nicht wieder die gesprungen
schön scharf anbraten und dann raus
nehmen
[Musik]
ich glaube ich ein bisschen höher
bist du so bist dann individuell von
eurem herd abhängig machen
[Musik]
die leckerbissen ausgeht
als ich sagt euch gusseisen dass ich
wenn ihr noch nie damit gekocht habt es
ist wirklich ein komplett anderer
geschmack nein jetzt war das fleisch
haben dass ich nur angebraten
ich nehme jetzt nochmal olivenöl dann
hier die zwiebel und knoblauch würfel
bis klassisch übrig wie gesagt für
volkan da kommt ja auch noch das heißt
er kriegt dann im kleinen hubert tork
kriegt er seine organe fraktion wobei
der monat der vielleicht ja auch mit
zwei drei leute ja auf jeden fall
[Musik]
nach dem anbraten dann mit der
gemüsebrühe ablöschen
ich finde auch eine fleischwunde gerne
nehmen dann auf jeden fall wissen wir
jetzt mal paprikapulver edelsüß
lorbeerblätter stadt gemüsebrühe könnt
ihr auch in rodheim jackson kommt noch
ein bisschen
das lass ich das mal kurz aufkochen
früher alles gut und dann das fleisch
hätte dazu samt saft
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr nämlich schon mal den
großteil der arbeit erledigt da kommt
jetzt deckel drauf das ganze wandert
einfach in den backofen bei 160 grad für
ungefähr zwei stunden da wird nämlich
schön zart und den wolken einfach mache
ich auch gleich noch fertig hier sollte
der prinz position
es hat hier hinten in der schublade also
ich kenne weder in der heimat nicht aus
doch hier für mich ist ein unterschied
ob man in den backofen den links nicht
mit rein
so mache ich ihnen glücklich
ich habe ich jetzt auch den wirsing und
wir sind ja schon so ein wintergemüses
und winter kroll und der ist wirklich
super gesund man kann ganz viel damit
machen entweder im eintopf
ihr könnt krautwickel ausmachen also sag
jetzt wirklich ganz ganz viele tolle
rezepte vor allem finde ich die farbe
auf so genial und wirsing ist ultra
gesund da ist vitamin e mittleren
vitamin d sex gehabt folsäure ihr habt
eisen mit dabei also wir sehen sollte
schon vor allem im winter aber am
speiseplan stehen
ich nehme jetzt lieber die äußersten
blätter ab das sind schöne stoppte den
hof ddp
aber auch weil gedacht und dann schneide
ich den einfach in streifen und der
kommt später mit mal da will ich jetzt
ne also so megawatt der kommt wirklich
zum schluss betragen so die letzte halbe
stunde mit den erbsen rebecca diesen
harten strommitte nämlich einfach raus
[Musik]
so eine riesenmenge jetzt bereiten wir
den das brot zu und zwar nimmt jetzt
einfach ganz viele mehr
ich habe jetzt hier auch ein ding ja
denn da ist ja wirklich ohne kneten da
ist ganz ganz flüssig auf mehr
ausschütten
wir sind jetzt hier auch richtig schön
diese teig strukturen guckt wie die hefe
wunderschön aufgegangen ist und aus dem
teig könnt ihr jetzt entweder parkett
fort so wäre jetzt paket machen möchte
es auch wie das magische wort jetzt
sozusagen und ihr macht einfach ein foto
wenn ihr parkett macht könnt ihr ein
backblech benutzen oder auch ganz
einfach ein normales backblech als ihr
braucht wirklich keine besonderen dinge
stellt dann in den backofen bei 200 40
grad mit einem schälchen wasser am
besten wegen wegen der dampf bildung
oder im dampf backofen
ich mache jetzt aber an brot raus und
ich habe jetzt hier zwar dampf backofen
aber ich nutze jetzt einfach den großen
topf als dampf backofen
denn der hat ja hier in eine decke und
wände täglich zu ist dann kondensiert er
das wasser dann verdampft das wasser und
kondensiert hier an der oberfläche an
diesem kleinen noppen und tropft wieder
aufs brot runter und so bekommen sie
eine richtig schöne kruste
also machen wir es gleich danach mal
auch keinen dampf offen dafür
ich halte es jetzt allerdings macht zwei
pro draus und aus deiner menge machen
wir noch mini pro tag ja das darfst du
dann gleich machen dann nochmal mail
obendrauf auf die hände auch guck mal
von außen nach innen einfach so
zusammenfassen die hände immer so ein
bisschen bemühen und so in der mitte
zusammen fahren dann ein bisschen mehl
auf dem boden des topfes
und mit der naht nach unten einfach rein
legen jetzt der deckel drauf dann stelle
ich das in den kalten backofen denn der
backofen der erhalt der auf und die
aufheizzeit nutzt das brot auch noch zum
aufgehen
30 minuten dann bei 200 grad deckel weg
und dann noch mal 15 minuten ungefähr
kann auch seinen zehn minuten weist
bisschen kleiner ist
[Musik]
die goldene mitte wir sollten öfter hier
drehen
[Musik]
es sieht das gut aus oder sieht es gut
aus sieht wunderbar aus dass es ganz
kurz abkühlen und dann nehme ich aber
raus und gibt es dann geht direkt auf so
ein abkühlt
denn wenn das boot im topf bleibt dann
schwitzt ist natürlich und wird wieder
weil ich uns wohl nicht wir wollen ja
ein schönes knuspriges brot aus
[Musik]
aber was schön war in der schüssel voll
und ganz schlüssel morgens ins glas sie
sorgte für eineinhalb stunden sind jetzt
vergangen war
so sieht der eintopf geradeaus musst du
echt immer daran denken die töpfe sind
super super heiß also ich habe es mal
den rosenstengel entfernt dann gebe ich
jetzt die erbsen rein wirsing
ich denke das sollte allein durch den
dampf gut nochmal zurück gehen jetzt
einfach noch mal ich werde jetzt erst
noch mal für eine stunde fast rein geben
also dann insgesamt zweieinhalb stunden
je länger umso zarter ist das fleisch
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es einmal bedroht frisch
geschnitten
murat kandidiert und dann gleich
bescheid geben oder mag ich erstmal
verkosten
ich probiere erstmal und jetzt der
schmeckt auch die anderen okay
guck mal hier
[Musik]
mittlerweile sieht er hier auch echt
ganz andere sache sagen also küche
hammer so gut wie fertig dekoriert hier
den laden haben us forscher dekoriert oh
mein gott ich habe es jetzt auch extra
nicht mit chili gewürzt denn ich habe
mir gedacht das mod 10 std olivenöl
einfach ein bisschen aufs brot drauf zum
zocken oder hier reihen sich hier mit
rainer hersteller aus schärfer also wenn
ihr ein bisschen chili olivenöl
draufgepackt halt sein olivenöl und
schillig das echt schon ziemlich kurz
ein bisschen habanero gegen löwen haben
ja ich finde ich auch mega erlebnis
einfach so was richtig warm ist und uns
einfach kreisen wintertagen kalten
wintertag karl lamers nicht aber aber
wieder ganztags opiaten gearbeitet alles
aufgegangen
aber schön weich geworden ist unserem
iraci leben
das heißt bei dienstreisen weiteres
rezept nach machen möchtet dann könnt
ihr gerne nachlesen auf sallys - blog.de
wir machen die tiere fertig ersten jetzt
alle noch in ruhe
danach gibt es auch kinderpunsch für
alle hier noch wegen für wolken und dann
machen wir hier sauber und morgen geht
hier die weihnachtsbäckerei jungs genau
zweieinhalb zimmer ist drin gehabt an
abschlüssen also sie können es auch mal
drei vier fünf sechs jahren ist da will
ich egal wirklich optimal anderem aus
zweieinhalb wenn ich opfer sagt und
darum bleibt ja auch schön warm das
heißt dann kann das aus waren und es ist
immer noch einer stunde ist auch noch
mal und ich würd wenn ihr das ganze an
weihnachten anrichtet finde ich auch
schon mit dem mini gusseisen nimmt die
wir freuen für die brötchen genommen
haben wenn er die vor wärmt und daran
das gericht rein macht dann bleibt es
auch noch schön warm am tisch dann
zeigen wir euch noch ein bisschen den
laden dem fertig geschnitten und hoffen
dass wir uns bald sehen
dankeschön fürs zuschauen wenn wir zum
sport machen wo sich menschen durch
diese musste zwei crews nicht
unterstellen und zum foto machen können
ist voller romantik so 11
[Musik]